We can debate whether it makes sense, but
Michael Bloomberg is now pretty damn [inaudible],
solidly
in third place nationally in the 2020 democratic
primary Beigel Bloomberg has pulled ahead
of now fourth place, Elizabeth Warren, certainly
ahead of now fifth place.
Pete, Buddha judge, and if Joe Biden continues
his downward trajectory dropping like a lead
balloon over the last 10 days and Michael
Bloomberg keeps gaining at the rate that he
has been, Bloomberg could conceivably be in
second place nationally before super Tuesday.
I don't totally understand what's going on,
but I want to go through the data with you
and see if we can figure out what is going
on here.
Let's check out the latest polling.
As you can see, Michael blow Bloomberg.
If you're watching along with me polling 1516
and 17 in three of the last five national
polls, no lower than 11 in any of those.
When we look at his trajectory on your screen,
you will see the red arrow pointing to the
orange line, which is Michael Bloomberg entering
the race at 2.5% in mid November.
Climbing to where he is now in third place
with an average of 14.2% in recent polling
nationally.
And then when you look at Biden's trajectory
there, you see this just drastic decline.
If the trend continues, Bloomberg could again
pass Biden within about 10 days.
Looking now at the exact numbers by candidate,
you will see that Joe Biden is just five points
ahead of Michael Bloomberg, 19.2 to 14.2 if
Biden loses two and a half points and Bloomberg
gains two-and-a-half, if Bloomberg gains three
and Biden loses two, any combination that
adds up to five, a five point swing, they
will be tied.
And this will absolutely shake up the democratic
primary on super Tuesday.
We'll look at some of those specific state
polls in a second.
Now remember, this is all happening after
our friend Benjamin Dixon, uh, unearthed some
audio that was available on YouTube, but Ben
found it, subtitled it and publicized it in
which Michael Bloomberg speaks very insensitively
on the issue of race related to young black
men in the context of stop and frisk.
Millions and millions and millions of views.
Many people disgusted by the audio.
Some people don't care.
I mean, we got calls this week from viewers
who said, my parents like Bloomberg, I showed
them Ben Dickson's audio and they're still
going to, they don't like it, but they're
still going to vote for Michael Bloomberg.
I don't yet know how the post audio polling
will change for Michael Bloomberg, but if
I'm totally honest with you, I don't think
it's going to change that much.
Uh, sadly my, um, uh, the, the, the real question
that we're getting to is when does Bloomberg
start winning delegates?
Because remember, polling 5% nationally or
10 or even 14, the way that Michael Bloomberg
is doing now is not particularly useful unless
you can meet the 15% viability threshold in
some individual primaries and start winning
some delegates.
As you may know, Bloomberg got zero in Iowa,
New Hampshire because he skipped them.
Bloomberg is skipping Nevada and South Carolina.
Bloomberg has already this week been campaigning
in North Carolina and important super Tuesday
States.
So when you look at where we have polling
on super Tuesday, it's looking okay for Michael
Bloomberg.
There are a bunch of States that vote on super
Tuesday where the latest polls are from October.
Like Bloomberg wasn't even running then.
We have no idea what's going on.
So if you look at Virginia polling, you look
at Minnesota polling, there is no recent polling
out of those States.
We just don't know how Michael Bloomberg is
doing.
California, we have quite a bit of polling
and Bloomberg is not doing, well, only 4%
in California.
But then you look at Texas and last month
Bloomberg already was at 16 and he may be
higher.
Now you look at Florida, Bloomberg was at
17 in a recent poll, you look at North Carolina
where Bloomberg has been spending some time
this week at 15% so that is a fair number
of delegates.
And this is both disgusting because he's just
buying his way in.
I mean this is, this is the height of or the
bottom of the barrel of depending on how you
want to think about it.
This is the height of the, uh, of the oligarch
he of the kleptocracy.
And we're going to talk about that word in
the context of Bloomberg a little bit later
on today.
It's also fascinating though because the combination
of a bunch of establishment centrists splitting
some of the of the delegates so far, Biden,
budaj edge and Klobuchar on the other hand,
because there's a big division between the
candidates, you have Bernie Sanders doing
very well winning the popular vote in both
Iowa and New Hampshire and yet not currently
leading in delegates.
It's fascinating that Michael Bloomberg may
soon get himself not just a second place in
the popular vote nationally.
He may end up actually getting more delegates
than a number of the other primary or or sort
of a, uh, more likely candidates.
Last thing, and I want to talk about, I want
to devote a little bit of time to this because
it is so weird.
There is some reason that must explain why
Michael Bloomberg so easily and so thoroughly
triggers Donald Trump
and that's what
I want to talk about next.